バイリンガルの
人が言語を切り替えると、
音を別の方法で
つなぎ合わせているだけでなく、どの
言語でも同じだと思われる音の多くが変わっているように見えることがよくあることに気づいたことがありますか?
私が日本語を学び始めたとき、この現象は私に多くの
悩みを与えたように思えますが、おそらく私が
日本語を教え始めたときはさらにもっと
悩みました。なぜこのようなことが起こるのかと尋ねられるかもしれませんが、これは単なる音程の問題ではないので、答えるのに苦労するでしょう。
アクセント、そして
それは
私たちが一般的に教えられているような発音の問題だけではありません。つまり、
舌をどこに置く必要があるか、口を
どのくらい開ける必要があるか、唇をどのくらい丸くする
必要があるかなどです。
これらのことと
いくつかのことの組み合わせです。
高度な言語知識がなければ、特定するのが非常に難しいその他の要素。私は
当初、
大学で学んだ言語知識と、卒業
後に学んだその他のリソースを使用してこのトピックを教えようとしましたが、
それが難しいことがわかりました。
これは裏目に出ることが多いのですが、これは、
基本的な音声周波数など、この現象に寄与する変数には、
独自の長い
説明が必要になることが多く、それらをすべてまとめて一貫したフレームワークに統合しようとすると、これらの説明に
さらに警告 ODS のリストが必要になる可能性があるため
です。 このトピックに関する私の最初のレッスンは
少し内容が膨らみ、
特に初心者にとっては理解しにくいものでした。本質的に
誰も「ああ、それが
今起こっていることです」とは言いませんでした。
それは本当に役に立ちますが、私は
このトピックを完全に放棄したくなかったのです。
この現象を均一に理解することは、1
人が多くの悪い
習慣の形成を防ぐのに大いに役立ち、2人は、そうしないと気づき始めるまでに何年もかかる可能性のある
多くのことを認識し、その後無意識に模倣することを学ぶのに非常に役立ちます。
このトピックに関する私の最初のビデオを見て、
根本的に異なる
角度から物事にアプローチしてみました。それがこのレッスンです。
これは私のパトレオン シリーズ
日本語音声学のエピソード 5.1 全体です。
このビデオでは、この
音声変化現象に、声変わり現象にアプローチしようとしています。 最も
正確または学術的な方法ですが、
理解しやすく、
さらに重要なことに、
初心者と中級者の学習者にとって実際に実用的であると私が信じたい方法で、私が
このトピックについて何年も学び始めたときに見たいと思っていたビデオを作成しようとしました
このレッスンを公開する
理由はいくつかあります。 1 つは、多くの人にとって
非常に有益であるともう一度考えたいから
2 は、私は
父親だから、休暇が近づいているので、
忙しくなってきていますが、続けなければなりません
YouTube のアルゴリズムを緩和すること、そして 3 つ目は、
日本語の音声学が現在年間購読料から 16% オフになっているためです。
これは、年間購読料に対してこれまでに提供した中で最大の割引であり、
それは年末まで続く予定です。
人々に来てもらうための最良の方法だと考えました。
適切なサンプルを一般に公開することになるので、
これがそれです。L が終わったら、
このトピックに関連するいくつかの点を追加するつもりですが、
今のところは、
おそらくビデオ
自体に語ってもらうのが最善です。
みなさん、こんにちは。そして、
dogen による日本語音声学のエピソード 5.1 へようこそ。このレッスンでは、
典型的な日本語の声や話し方が、典型的
なアメリカ英語の声や
話し方とどのように違うのかを見ていきます。まず最初に、何をするのかを見ていきます。
このレッスンで「声」と言うとき、「声」とはどういう意味ですか、「話し方」とは何を意味しますか?
私は人の
音声器官について話しているので、喉、舌、
鼻腔などです。明らかに、あなた
の音声器官を根本的に変えることはできません。 話し方は使い方を変えることができます。
これが
このレッスンで話し方の意味するところです。
話し方とは、話者の
言語器官のデフォルト設定のようなものであり、
特定の言語を話すときの一般的な雰囲気や雰囲気さえ指します。
これがそのことです。
残りのレッスンは、
日本語の話し方が
英語の話し方とどう違うのかについて考えていきます。
十分長く勉強すれば、ほとんどの
人は、日本語の話し方が英語の話し方とどのように違うのか、ある程度の感覚を掴めると思います。 この
プロセスは、
特に
典型的な日本語の教室コースを受講している場合、数年とは言わないまでも数か月かかることがよくあります。
これは主に、
ほとんどの学習者に日本語の話し方と英語の話し方を
簡単に比較する機会が与えられないためだと思います。
1 人のスピーカーが 2 つのスタイルを切り替えるのを聞くことができます。1 人の
スピーカーが
2 つのスタイルをデモンストレーションするのを聞くことができれば、さらに効果的ですが、
まったく同じ単語やフレーズについてです。それが
今から行うことです。
NHKの
発音学校に通った一人の日本語ネイティブスピーカーの話を聞いてください。彼は
英語も流暢で、このトピックの経験があります。2
つの話し方を切り替えます
が、最初は1つの言語で
彼女が英語のフレーズを言うのを聞きます。あなたは
疲れているようです、日本語で 話し方を変えると
彼女が全く同じフレーズを言うのが聞こえます
が、英語の話し方では
2 つの
話し方の違いの一部は非常に小さいので、見て
いる人には
静かな部屋で良い
ヘッドフォンを使って聞いてみることをお勧めします。」 ここで皆さんに少し時間を与えますが、
準備はできていますか? まず、
日本語の話し方の録音を 3 回聞きます。
スロースロー、次に通常の
速度で聞きます。次に、
英語の話し方の録音をもう一度
同じ方法で聞きます。それから、
2 つのスタイルを続けて聞くよ、それでは
聞いてみましょう、君の様子
[音楽]
疲れているようだ、疲れているようだ、疲れているようだ、疲れているようだ、疲れているようだ、
疲れているようだ
英語のフレーズに対して 2 つのスタイルを連続して比較しました。
日本語のフレーズに対して同じことをしてみましょう。スピーカーは
今度はこう言うでしょう。日本語の会話を聞く前のように、日本語で日本に行きたいです。
英語を話すスタイルのスタイルを言ってください。そうすれば、
2 つのスタイルが続けて言われるのが聞こえます。わかりました、聞きましょう、それで、
あなたは 2 つの話し方の違いをどのように感じますか。皆さんは 2 つの話し方の違いを明らかに説明します。
言い方は様々ですが、私は次
のように物事を要約したいと思います
日本語の話し方は日本文化に似ています
明確に定義され、
一貫性があり、秩序ある アメリカ英語の
話し方 一方では
アメリカ文化に似ています
リラックスした柔軟で自由です 日本語の
話し方 明確に定義された、
一貫性があり、秩序ある アメリカ人の
話し方 リラックスした、柔軟で自由な
話し方 これはおそらく非常に曖昧で役に立たないように
聞こえることに気づきました。そこで、2 つの話し方の具体的な違いをいくつか探っていきます。話し方を切り替える方法を詳しく探っていきます。
スタイルによって、同じ単語
やフレーズが根本的に
異なって聞こえることがあります。 日本語の話し方の空気の流れから始めましょう。
フレーズ全体で吐き出される空気の量は、かなり規則的で一定です。 これも
また一貫性があり、整然としています。
一方、英語の話し方は、
より規則的です。 リラックスしていて柔軟性があり、
その結果、フレーズの終わりに向けて話者の速度が相対的に少し遅くなります。
話者の速度が遅くなると、喉を通過する空気の量も
遅くなり、
少しだけ
きしむ声が発生します。 フレーズの
最後に音が出るボーカルフライとして知られることもありますが、
もう一度聞いてみて、
日本語スタイルの息づかいが
最初から最後までほぼ一定であるのに対し、
英語圏のスタイルでは
一貫性が低いことに注目してください。 その結果、フレーズの
最後にちょっと声が荒くなってしまうのですが、
疲れているようです、疲れているようです、疲れているようです、疲れているようです、疲れているようです、疲れているようです、だから
もう少しリラックスしたり、決めかねた
態度で物事を言うだけで、私たちは 結局、私たちのスピーチ
に根本的に異なる声質を導入することになります。
興味深いです。ここ
にレッスン 5 で学んだ別の例があります。
日本語のタイミングは通常、音節では
なくモーラで測定され、
一般的に日本語で言えば、
これらの MOA またはビートはそれぞれ同じセットを持っています
長さは再び
一貫していますが、
リラックスした柔軟な方法で話すと、
このタイミングを維持するのが難しくなる可能性があります。
たとえば、かわいいカライという単語を
正しい高さのアクセントで言ったとしても、
英語の話し方だと後回しになってしまう可能性があります。
時間通りに終わるのではなく、またカライのように最後にオフになるのはもっとカワイイです 2 つをネイティブの音声と背中合わせに比べてみてください
カウ
[音楽] カワイイ
カワイ [
音楽] カワイイ カワイイ
カワイイ 今では、スピーカーが決して
消えないわけではありません。 日本語ではその点できしむような声を使うのは、
確かにそうであるからです。同じ状況であれば、
日本語を母語話者とする人は
通常、英語を母語とする人よりもより明確で一貫性のある秩序
立った方法で話し、
その結果として一般的に言えば、話し言葉が
少なくなるからです。 日本語の末尾のきしむ声
最後に母音の例
これについてはレッスン 37 で話しますが、このように
綴られる日本語の「愛」では、
それぞれの母音が「
I
I」のように次々に発音され、非常に異なって聞こえます。
英語の単語「i i」では、
2 つの母音が「DI thong」またはある母音が別の母音に変化する音として発音されます。
日本語でそれぞれの母音がどのように明確に
発音されているかに注意しながら、2 つを背中合わせに比べてみてください。 一方、英語では、
I I I I I
I という 2 つの境界線はそれほど明確ではありません。そのため、日本語の話し方は、
より明確で一貫性があり、整然としています。リラックス
した態度で I と言えないわけではないことを覚えておいてください。なぜなら、
あなたは確かにそれができるからです。 一般的に、
明確に定義された一貫性のある秩序ある
方法で話すように努めれば、私やその他の日本語の単語やフレーズを、英語のアクセントが少なく自然な方法で言うのがおそらく簡単になるでしょう。それで、話し方のスタイルを変えることでどのように影響を受けるかを見てきました。
エアフローの
タイミングや母音に影響を与える
話し方によって影響を受ける可能性のあるものは他にもたくさんあります
が、これら
すべてを個別に特定して対処しようとするよりも、
少なくとも最初は
日本語の話し方の全体的な感覚を掴もうとする方がはるかに良いと私は強く信じています。
スタイル したがって、
日本語と英語で
話しているスタイルのバックタック録音をもう少し聞いて、このレッスンを終了したいと思います。これは少し漠然としているように思われるかもしれませんが、
ここで重要なことは、
2 つのスタイルがどのように異なるのかについての一般的な感覚をつかむことです。 はい、
準備はできていますか、
聞いてみましょう、おはよう、おはよう、おはよう、おはよう、おはよう、おはよう、おはよう、おはよう、おはよう、こんにちは、元気ですか、こんにちは、[
音楽]
あなた、こんにちは、元気ですか、こんにちは、
元気ですか
仕事が好きです
仕事が好きです 仕事が
好きです
仕事が好きです 仕事は好きです どうでしたか
無声化や無声化などの話し方についてはこのシリーズの後半でお話します
が、やはり一般的に
言えば、
明確に定義された一貫した秩序ある
方法で話そうとすると、日本語はより自然に聞こえるようになります。これは特にアメリカ人出身の場合に当てはまります。
英語の背景
として、人々は非常に
リラックスした柔軟で自由な方法で
今日から話す傾向があります。話し方に注意を
払ってみてください。
日本語の話し方と
アメリカ英語の話し方の大きな違いにすぐに気づき
始めるでしょう。 これらの違いに注意してください。
日本語の話し方を無意識かつ自然に再現する能力が
劇的に向上します。よし、
皆さん、今回のエピソードはここまでです。
次の日本語音声学のレッスンに役立つと幸いです。
このビデオの下のリンクをご覧ください。
皆さん、ありがとうございました。 引き続きのご支援を
よろしくお願いいたします。また近いうちにお話し
できるのを楽しみにしています。それではこれが教訓です。お気づきの方も
いるかもしれませんが、
このビデオのスピーカーは両方の言語に 100% 流暢です。
この話題についても非常に知識が豊富ですが、彼女は
バイリンガル環境で育ったわけではないので、
100%ネイティブではない
英語の発音が
話し方の違いにつながった例がいくつかあったかもしれませんが、
私は今でも彼女は正しいと思っています。
標準的な
日本語の話し方と
アメリカ英語の話し方の一般的な違いを説明する素晴らしい仕事でした。最後にもう 1 つ言及しておきたいのですが、
これはビデオの中で何度も言ったのです
が、明確に言ったことはありませんでした。
今すぐそうしましょう。言語とは
単に話したり、聞いたり、読んだり
書いたりするだけではなく、性格や文化でもあるということです。つまり、
同じピッチアクセント、
発音、話し方をする 2 人がいて、そのうちの
1 人がより日本語的なマナーを使用し、
ある種の
典型的な日本人の性格なので、
おそらく彼らは一般的に謙虚で人当たりが
良いのでしょう。音自体は同じであるにもかかわらず、その人の日本語はほとんどの
状況で
ネイティブスピーカーにとってより自然に見えるでしょ
う。
バイリンガルは
言語を話したり、切り替えたりします。なぜなら、私たちは
通常、言語に関しては音に集中するように教えられているからです。
たとえ、
それらの
違いが何であるかを明確に表現できなくても、話し方の違いに気づくようになるからです。
その言語が生まれた2つの文化の違いに基づいて、話者が自分自身をどう保つかについての小さな違いに気づいていないのに、私たちは
これらの
違いすべてを声のせいだと考えてしまい、その
人の声そのものだと言ってしまうのだと思います。 変わった、
あるいはその
人の性格が変わったように性格と言うこともありますが、これが
私が言いたいのは、
言語は孤立して存在するものではなく、本質的にその言語が由来
する文化と結びついているということであり、
そのためであるということです。 全体的に日本人になればなるほど、
話し言葉を含む日本語のあらゆる側面がより自然に見えるように
なります。もちろん、
不快になるまで性格を変えるべきではありません。
ガイドラインには多くの例外があります。 私たちは、
日本人には特に
謙虚でもなく、愛想も良くない人がたくさんいるということを知りましたが、特に早い段階で日本語の話し言葉の
一般的な傾向
や
日本文化の一般的な傾向や特徴を意識すれば、
それは可能になります。
非常に助けになります。もう一度言いますが、日本語は
一般的に、明確に一貫した
秩序ある方法で話されており、
日本では一般に、声の変化の多くの原因となるこれら 2 つのことを組み合わせると、謙虚で調和のとれた方法で行動することが好まれます。
またまた、
日本語
音声学の年間購読料が大幅に割引されます。このビデオが役立つと思われた場合は、
おそらくシリーズの残りの部分も
同様に役立つと思われるため、
近日公開予定のコメディビデオの登録を検討してください。